trying to give you some some options for
your anything I hate sushi
it is definitely food I could eat every
day no problem juice vendors at the mall
like free smoothie always yes you take
this unity this is nigiri sushi it's a
it's a type of sushi also Louise is out
sick today so I get to eat this burrito
five days of this no problem five months
no problem maybe five years I can't say
FIFO Nathan can't take smoothie some
white girl I got this movie and then I
brought this smoothie come home what a
burrito every day I start feeling happy
this is expensive yeah I'm on a budget
Louise Louise is sick again so we are
eating and eating the whole thing the
whole thing I have a sip of it no I just
please have sick no I'm good we were
just so sure you weren't gonna be here
that Kyle just got this shitty do you
know was it making you feel any better
no it's kind of stupid to think that you
could become sick of sushi you know how
much my student loan bill is every month
this could be leaking out of my eyeballs
and I still wouldn't complain I mean
appetizing not really but it's free so
like we're gonna eat it I'm gonna eat it
let's talk about your pimp I've got a
feeling there's gonna be some poops I
have like an iron stomach so taste a lot
to really like to make my foots weird
it's been an emotional journey the wow
factor is a little bit like dull yeah
the wow factor is gone but I'm still
happy with it I have no problem with
breakfast burritos
I feel like the goal of this video was
to have us be sick of our favorite food
but you know there's people starving out
there that's not this kind of video
we're grateful I could go on yeah I
could do just everyday forever at the
birth well you popped my back
she's oh my god smell that